people coming you they pulled up
welcome
and earlier this week I I spoke to
magnus carlsen was the the best player
in the world right now is yes and I
asked him about you and asked him to
describe you and he said she is very
aggressive and she's very dangerous
Alexey why do you like that description
is that is it I'm sorry it's good that
you asked him now and not two months
before because I played with him in in
Mexico in December so I think he said it
by his own experience because actually I
beat him once the match he won't but I
beat him once and it was some unexpected
attack which he blundered and he got
surprised but are you kind of is this
your style i aggressive in the way yes i
was very famous already when I was very
young age of seven eight nine when I
started to have my first international
success I started to play chess when I
was five and I always liked very much
attacking play and hunt for the King and
and that's why everybody was kind of
giving me the name that I'm very
dangerous and I'm very aggressive and
later on also when I played against
Kasparov it was known that he doesn't
like when you attack his King and that's
what I was going for and you actually
you you won over him and you've beaten
nine world champions Kasparov Karpov and
and many others I who was the easiest
well I'm happy that I beat many of them
actually Karpov I beat many times but as
far as I beat only once and but it's
very interesting that for example
against Kasparov when I won against him
it was it was special but another time
when I made two draws in a mini match it
was much more intensive and special to
me
the battle was much more bloodier I see
ok
and how do do these these guys react
when you when you beat them well they
are not happy especially when I was
little it was very difficult for my
opponent's first Grandmaster I beat he
took it very difficult when he left the
hole he was hitting his head in the
elevator
I mean it's everybody's handling it in a
different way it's a very male-dominated
dominated world the chess world I didn't
have it have you had to adapt or how did
you adapt I mean well I grew up in a
very special family that I have two
older sisters and my parents believe
that women are capable to reach the same
results as men and then in chess there
was like many many years ago like 30
years ago that the chess is separated
woman and man and I grew up in an
environment where they taught me and
they believed in me that I'm capable to
reach the highest and that's how it was
very natural for me to play against man
and when I want it increased my
self-confidence and but did you have to
be like the men or could did you could
you have your own style or how did you I
think generally everybody has their own
style but I remember my trainer
'his was saying many times that and some
of the my colleagues at you're a man
because I have this man way of thinking
I grew up between men I was competing
between adults all the time and I'm a
very rational thinker so in some ways I
think like a man but actually I hope I
look like a woman um your father he is a
psychologist and he as I understand it
he had a plan for you
well actually before he got married him
he even met my mother he had his ideas
after reading and the teaching also that
he wanted to specialize on one specific
field once he's going to have children
and when he met my mother then my mother
is from karpati from Ukraine Hungarian
part of Ukraine and he was telling my
mother his ideas that he wants to have
six children and they are not going to
go to school they will be specialized on
events specific field at a very early
age and focus on that and be champions
or vote famous on that field and well at
first my mother said this guy is crazy
and then my father went home to Budapest
later on they met again and then
actually they got married then three of
us was born but it was enough this was
like an experiment well yeah he was very
much believed in his idea that he's
going to be focusing on one specific
field because he believed that the
school system is not right and the kids
are not developing so well as if you
focus on something and well my kids are
in school and yeah I can kind of agree
with him that school is not where you're
there to learn all the time it's more
like a social place and that kids are
getting tired but I mean if you want to
focus and you want to get the knowledge
and academic knowledge I mean school is
not the best place and this is why he
wrote he wrote a book called how to
educate a genius is it yes and when did
that would come out was that before or
after 88 88 when I was 12 years old and
after everyone the first chess Olympia
with these resistors do you think this
is it is this possible bringing up
children like this focusing on one thing
and make them geniuses obviously
well may I ask you you have children
being aggressive and dangerous I mean I
have children yes I had for him any 45
year old daughter no I was six and a
half year old daughter and eight and a
half my boy it is very interesting that
after I I had kids actually I had both
of them I was playing in the candidates
matches and when I was preparing with a
very famous Grandmaster he was helping
me and he said yeah we can work and
everything is okay but after you became
a mother you're not such a killer yeah
you lose lost your killer instinct so I
was no I was denying no way but of
course I became different after I became
mother of course priorities shuffled
completely and the tournament just is
not as important anymore at all but it's
still important for you're still playing
and I'm still playing and but I don't
have enough time for preparation there's
still the best best woman female player
in the world yes I took such a lead when
I was very young girl even I was off I
became number one already that the gap
is too big so say you know what you know
what on the school's I can't resist a
commercial break if you're worried about
a school you know which country is the
best schools in the world just bring him
to Finland just bring your defender
I think that is genius in every child I
think every human being can become a
genius I don't know which is right
method sometimes time to think it's
right to have very hard training from
you're very small sometimes I think that
genius have to develop viñagrow then you
get some experience that it comes by
self but you know what would be your
genius if you were if someone trained
you as Doctor the word miss are very
good architecting me I should I've been
trying to ding gigantic buildings I see
yes
and what about you honor I am a writer
I'm an artist I have written 30 books
and they're only 2 about children and
this writing to create couldn't nobody
could stop that that was one of the
reasons for why my man had such problems
with me and what about you well I you
know I remember I was when I was 13 or
14 I was watching TV and there was a
politician on TV and he was talking
something I didn't understand the word
so I asked my dad you know what what's
that man isn't he's a politician
what do politicians do oh they are the
kind of guys who don't get any other
work
thank you so much for being here with us
and and the please don't leave yet
because we welcome serious threat and
poster
you